so hello ladies and gentlemen from both
hamburg and the san francisco bay area
in these
still very special and challenging times
welcome to today's broadcast on the
topic
sales emotion how to optimize your shake
flask and bioreactor cultures
our webinar today will be presented to
you by my colleagues in hartman and
ankita
both are amongst eppendorf's most
experienced application specialists in
regards to supporting scientists with
their suspension cell culture
applications
and i will give you a short introduction
about both in a minute
my name is christian harlan marketing
manager for instruments and systems at
eppendorf and i will be
your moderator for today's webinar
at the end of the presentation i would
like to give you a quick overview about
solutions that might be helpful for you
to improve your daily cell culture work
so let's go to
some technical information before we
start before we begin i would like to
encourage you all to get the most out of
this webinar by submitting
as many questions as you want at any
time you want during the presentation
simply type them into the ask a question
box on the left
and click send we will answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the webinar
if you have trouble to see or hear the
presentation click on the support tab at
the top right
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
on the left continuing education credits
can be obtained by clicking on the tab
at the top right and just following the
process
so and if you are interested in further
resources
you can go also to the resources tab by
simply clicking on it
and you will also find that during the
presentation we have a few qr codes for
you integrated
that might lead you to or will lead you
to further
content
all right now let me shortly introduce
the presenters of your webinar today as
i said
enos hartmann and ankita desai are
amongst our most experienced application
specialists focusing on suspension cell
culture applications and shakers and
bioreactors since years now
enos hardman is application specialist
cell handling i'm responsible for the
shakers and mixers since many years now
at ependorf
in hamburg in germany she joined the
company 12 years ago
and since then covered many cell culture
related topics and
obtained her diploma degree in biology
at the humboldt university in berlin
in germany and our second speaker
ankita desai is a bioprocess field
application specialist at m dorf in
north america
she supports customers with her
expertise in cell culture bioprocessing
and related applications after her
master's
pharmaceutical and pharmaceutical
sciences at the
northeastern university in boston she
has gained several
experiences working for global players
in the pharmaceutical industry
before she joined ebendorf and today we
are happy that ian
and keita are going to share their their
knowledge with us so
i will stop talking now let's get
started
enos and ankita this stage is all yours
thank you very much christian i would
like to start my name is emails
um welcome also from northern germany
and from akita side from the west coast
in
in the usa california and i would like
to start to
tell you what we have in the agenda for
the next let's say
40 minutes so first of all we would like
to
tell you why shakers and bioreactors are
used
then we will have a short comparison of
the two systems
and then probably the most interesting
for you can we give you some tips on how
to shake and steer cultures
and we will give you after that a short
introduction also on feeding cells so
introduction to different process
strategies
in the end christian we will hand over
to chris christian again and he will
give you a bit more insights on the
append of product solutions
so before we start we have a first poll
we would like to know a bit about your
experience so michelle can you
push out the pole
okay
ah i see sorry it was my fault now so
the question was do you already
work with shakers and bioreactors and
some of you
use shakers some of you use bioreactors
half
half
and some of you are very new to to both
systems
so i go back that is good so now i would
like
or we would like to tell you why these
systems are used so
a broad range of cell types and
organisms from very simple ones from
bacteria yeast and fungi for instance
to very complex plant cells ig insect
cells up to mammalian or even stem cells
are shaken or steered in shakers or
bioreactors
the importance in biotechnology industry
is immense
so of course in pharmaceutical and life
sciences
a very actual topic is vaccines of
course
for corona therapeutic proteins
antibodies up to emerging cell therapies
and stem cells
are produced in cells also food and feed
is an important topic here and beverages
everybody no yeast beer feed additives
but also flavors and vitamins
for all that you need to cultivate
cultures in a shake on a bioreactor
biofuels and chemicals so we talk here
about
um the important topic about
sustainability for instance
the replacement of
the addition of biopolymers for instance
or alternative fuels
from ilg for instance or platform
chemicals
so for all this you need to cultivate
cells
but the question is why using shakers
and bioreactors
these systems are used to optimize first
nutrient supply
second to stabilize the temperature and
third to make oxygen available to the
cells
so checking or steering in general means
culture improvement
so let's go to the first point nutrient
supply
just an easy example of a shake flask on
the left hand side
you see a static culture when
there is no shaking you have a
sedimentation
and worst case a gradient formation so
there is a limited and inhomogeneous
access to nutrients for the cells
so that means inhomogeneous and low cell
yields
when you start shaking or steering so
moving the liquid
the suspension will be uniformly
distributed
and you have an improved and homogeneous
access to nutrients
the second point also very important
yeah we did not ask that but i think
most of you apply temperature to the
system either by
having an incubated shaker having an
open air shaker in a temperature
controlled room
or using a temperature control for
bioreactors as well
temperature is an important
factor as well either first for
cell expansion or second
to um to have the optimum for the
product
you would like to produce in the
cultures or from the cultures
let's have a look at the cell expansion
so each culture has
its optimum so when we culture for
instance let's take simply e coli
at the at is optimum around 37 35
degrees
we have a nice exponential growth curve
but where if we have
higher temperatures or even lower
then we have a slowed growth
that is sometimes beneficial a slow
growth
is beneficial often for the
production of therapeutic protein
expression
um a lower it improves solubility of the
protein
by slowing down the cultures processes
also the protein is produced slower
plus also it reduces the degradation of
proteolytical
sensitive proteins
third probably the most important thing
why shakers and bioreactors are used is
the
oxygen availability oxygen is one of the
main influencing factors
um on aerobic cell growth so except for
some
anaerobic cultures where it's not
important this is
the limiting factor often in shakers and
bioreactors
oxygen is a key substrate for growth
production and maintenance activities
and cells cannot obtain oxygen
from the air in a non-compound form they
they need it um as dissolved oxygen
in the media so in compound format so
the problem is when you culture the
cells in the media
it has a very it has a low solubility in
the liquid so let's have a look
between the gas phase and the liquid
phase
you have your cell in the media of
course here for instance
e coli and you have oxygen in the gas
phase
oxygen must pass to the liquid phase and
then you have it in the compound format
but you have
a constant concentration drop and until
it reaches the cell
yeah you have another drop
so what shakers and stirrers do is they
increase the oxygen transfers but both
have different strategies
so let's have a look a shake flask very
simple
you have a flask and a cap and oxygen
passes by diffusion this should be
oxygen in the air
and you have only a still
surface here so no shaking that is
a small surface so the oxygen transfer
the surface for oxygen transfer is
relatively low
when you have shaking you have
a constant constantly formed swirl
building up and that means also that you
have a larger surface
a larger surface means a higher oxygen
transfer to the culture
and this swell is constantly moving
around
and giving new oxygen to the culture
depending on the rpm
you can adjust this well of course and
this is one factor to increase oxygen
transfer so for shakers
it is the available surface area for
diffusion of oxygen
into the media and broth what is
improved so
i would ankita how is it in bioreactors
thank you anna's um so uh in a typical
bioreactor which is a stirred tank
vessel
uh you have a sparger which is
which can be either open pipe sparger
ringsparter or
an l-shaped spotter depending on the
type of application or the process needs
uh which is also accompanied by an
impeller
for agitation so depending on the
constant feedback from a do sensor
air or pure oxygen can be actively
pumped into the culture via this partner
which causes a creation of gas bubbles
in the bioreactor
and stirring allows proper mixing of the
sculpture
and improves oxygenation by evenly
dispersing these gas bubbles in the
contract
so this provides a large surface area
for
uh oxygen transfer from gas phase to the
liquid phase
back to
thanks ankita there are two terms that
you should know when you talk about
oxygen transfer and also two terms you
can measure in the culture
we talk here about the terms otr and our
so what is it again this picture the gas
and the liquid phase could be a
bioreactor or a shaker with a
media in it so we have either bacteria
or you cultivate mammalian cells please
not in one tank otherwise
the bacteria would overgrow the
mammalian cells
the otr means oxygen transfer rate
that means the rate at which
oxygen gas is transferred from the air
to the liquid
over a given period of time and this can
be measured
then we have the our so the oxygen
uptake rate and this is
the time the rate at which the cells
come
consume oxygen
over time so this you can measure in
well
as well um
the in generally or simplified one can
say that the oxygen transfer rate so the
otr
is is the limiting factor and the otr
defines the maximum cell density
so this is the more important thing to
talk about
because the cell's oxygen uptake depends
on the otr
let us have a look in a shake flush to
maybe a bit better explain
how what happens with the oxygen and
what is otr and our influence
so here you agitate a culture you have a
temperature and e coli again let's take
it as
example is growing nicely exponentially
growth
the oxygen uptake the oxygen uptake rate
in accordance with that also the our so
the oxygen
uptake rate in the cell goes up
whereas you see here the liquids oxygen
decreases because of that
because the cell is taking oxygen up
decrease in the liquid occurs
but of course this is not meaning
because of shaking and steering there is
always introduced new oxygen into the
culture
so in best case there is a balance
between oxygen introduction
and oxygen uptake and this you can
control
with agitation fill aeration and other
parameters with shakers and bioreactor
now let's talk a bit about math very
shortly only and i would like to hand
over to our bioprocess
application specialist ankita again
thanks enes um so this slide describes
how
otr can actually be calculated um
so just to give a snapshot kla which is
a volumetric mass transfer coefficient
actually describes the maximum oxygen
transfer that can be achieved in a
system
uh within a given set of operating
conditions
so um the driving force for this
transfer of oxygen from the gas phase to
the liquid phase is actually the
gradient between the concentration of
oxygen
and the interface uh and that in the
bulk liquid
so essentially when an equilibrium is
reached there is no more oxygen transfer
from gas to liquid phase and the otr
would then become
zero um for typical bacterial
and yeast cultures um the critical
oxygen concentration
is usually 10 to 50 percent of air
saturation
so above that critical level the oxygen
concentration no longer limits the cell
growth
um so in order to have an optimum growth
it is important to maintain vo levels
above the critical value
by sparging the bioreactor with air or
pure oxygen
so like we saw in the previous slide
during those initial days in culture
when the cell density is low
the our is less than otr but as the
cells start multiplying and reach higher
cell densities
it is important to maintain otr values
which are equal or exceeding
the our of the growing cells um so in
this graph we also have
a a kla profile of bioblue 3c macrospot
vessels at different tip speeds
um essentially uh maintaining a
constant kla between different vessels
of different sizes is one of the most
commonly used strategies for our cell
culture scale up
since uh in this case kla or otr could
very well be the limiting factor which
would then control the growth rate of
yourself
um so let's talk a little bit more about
the kla
so kla is the volumetric mass transfer
coefficient
uh which is a measurement of the
capacity of the bioreactor to transfer
oxygen into the culture
uh under given set of operating
conditions
so when we're talking about the scale up
of bioreactors
kla is a term which is heard very often
a very common scale-up strategy is to
select equipment of different sizes
which have
similar kla capabilities so that
processes at
a small scale r d equipment can be
successfully replicated
at a larger production scale systems
um a typical kla based scale up can be
performed by maintaining constant kla
values among different vessels providing
flexibility to then
accommodate different types of cell
lines uh here we just have some of the
factors
which affect kla in both shakers as well
as bioreactors
so there could be some equipment
specific parameters like the vessel
geometry
uh stereotype installation conditions
some process parameters like agitation
rate
filling addition rate uh type of gassing
device or dispatcher
as well as pressure and uh it also
depends on the properties of the liquid
medium
uh meaning the density uh viscosity
surface tension as well as
coalescence properties
thank you here go ahead
yeah we have some support material also
for you so if you want to know more
how to measure oxygen transfer rate for
instance in bioreactors and fermentation
vessels
it will be online soon so check the
appendoff website
if you would like to have it now please
send
drop us an email by process minus
experts at appendoff.com or just
via lab routes for shake flask um there
is also
online for instance a kll calculator so
you can also um calculate
the kla by this and you type in just in
this
if you check the qr code here you go to
the website you can
type in the shake flask size fill volume
rpm
and you can determine yeah it gives you
a
the kla so the ration efficiency of the
system with the parameters you apply
which is for the shaker the rpm flask
and fill volume
averagely okay so now we
come already to the next
chapter so a short comparison of the
system so what are
the differences what are the
similarities
and here we have also um
a short question for you
and the question is
what are your working volumes so
michelle please drop the question
up
so with what volumes do you work in your
daily daily lab routine with shakers and
bioreactors
so um let us compare the system
so here the first difference is of
course a shaker
um you have a lower investment for a
bioreactor
so it's relatively low and shike flasks
are not
as expensive even though
[Music]
a single-use vessel could have its price
as well
bioreactors mean a larger invest
technical expertise for a shaker
you don't need it maybe there are some
things to consider but
it's everybody can use a shaker whereas
a bioreactor
needs a certain kind of technical
expertise
because it's more complex for the
working volumes and the experimental
throughput
you can achieve with these systems let's
first have a look at the working volumes
um with the shaker you can go up maximum
depending on what
yeah flask size you use and there are
different
flasks where you can also achieve higher
fill volumes with special designs we
come
later to it so let's say 2 liter per
flask
and down if you use for instance plates
down to one milliliter
or even lower 500 200 microliter is okay
in a deep well plate to use
for bioreactors um you cannot go so low
but you can start with to yeah i think
350 around
milli milliliter but you can scale up of
course to
production years 2000 liter the
throughput also is vice versa if you for
instance use plates you have 96 words in
a 96 well played as a name set
and if you have for instance a triple
stack of a shaker you can cultivate and
parallel more than
7000 cultures for bioreactors
it's low to medium so in parallel
with the mini bioreactor system parallel
system is 24
and and lower
so but shakers and bioreactors team up
very well
so i give over to ankita
to explain shortly the workflow thank
you anna
um so here we have a typical uh scale-up
workflow
in this slide so uh while the main
goal of a scale-up process or scaling up
your process
is to ensure large-scale production of
the product
all the while maintaining the desired
product qualities and characteristics
that are obtained at the small scale
to this end we start with the small
scale experiments in
in shake flask to provide the initial
cell growth data
and provide seed cultures screening can
be performed
uh then starting with mini bioreactors
uh which would provide small scale
solutions at an
r d scale including media design or
optimization of different parameters
um next up would be our bench scale
systems which provide a great tool for
process development and technology
transfer uh to eventually scale the
process up all the way to pilot of
production skill systems
yes um we saw already in at the first
part that the liquid movement is
different
and we get to it in the next chapter a
bit more
and shakers have an orbital um shaking
movement i will tell you in the next
chapter a bit about this
and bioreactors have a third tank
principle so with a stirrer
and introducing oxygen by bubble
formation
concerning process control and process
monitoring
of course for bioreactors is broad and
flexible
and for shakers it's agitation and you
can
control chamber conditions we see on the
next slide
what you can control and process
monitoring there are options
you can add instruments to the shaker
for instance
sensors so the basic process control and
shakers you have
different shaker types you can decide
for
for instance open air the very simplest
one if you have a temperature controlled
room
that offers the control of agitation
then you have the most important shakers
incubated and incubated co2 shakers
depending
if you have the co2 for mammalian cells
where you have co2 and humidity control
and of course temperature control and
then you have the incubated
shakers which offer temperature control
plus also
refrigeration and optionally for ig
or other photosynthetic organism you can
add optionally photosynthetic lights
process control just for um what you can
do in
an incubator incubated shakers you can
also um at least in our shape but
operating
as a with a program so you can add
several
steps for instance meaning the easiest
thing just to understand
step one would be growing at the the
sales optimum 37 degrees
and 250 rpm and then maybe it's weekend
and you want to store the culture safely
at cool temperature so you can stop the
curve with setting four degrees or 10
degrees
with even off or low shaking so again
you can come
monday morning in the lab and you have
yeah you can control the growth curve
and you can do also different
programming types if you have
photosynthetic lights for instance
circadian rhythms etc
you can add accessories
[Music]
for instance there are companies
offering in flask feeding
um if you want or there are companies
offering in flask monitoring um they are
of course also
compatible with our system they are
comfortable with all shakers
um you can monitor for instance biomass
and ph or also do
there is oops for instance also that
company aquila or
pre-sense is another company
yes um yes with this i would like to
hand over to ankita because a bioreactor
is
more than a vessel thank you nez
um so here um uh what i'll be talking
about is a basic uh
bar reactor uh control and the
flexibility that it offers
so a bioreactor itself is more than a
vessel
so here um we just have a little cartoon
where bioreactor is essentially compared
to a fish tank so to speak
wherein the tank itself is the
bioreactor vessel which houses the
culture
um which is also called the vessel
we also have the water which is compared
to the medium for silk road
uh we have fish which are compared to
the cells growing in the fish tank
um we have uh agitation going on
in the vessel which is going to be done
via the agitator and
agitation shaft as well as the impellers
uh the fish food
or the glucose amino acid various
nutrient substrates that are going to be
added to the culture
uh we have the product of interest which
is going to be secreted
uh we have temperature a dissolved
oxygen as well as ph
control going on inside the muscle so
the main
idea is that by controlling the
different input parameters like
temperature
ph dissolved oxygen agitation nutrients
etc uh we are able to influence the
output variables like the desired
product yield and
cell growth uh bioreactors offer active
monitoring and control of various
parameters
uh just like temperature ph du um
agitation uh there is also active
contactive
control as well as monitoring of these
parameters using
feedback obtained uh from the sensors in
the vessels
uh you are able to implement different
feed strategies like a fed batch
continuous or perfusion culture
processes
um that can be done using the controller
capabilities
uh also because of the varied sizes
available
stir tank bioreactors also provide an
ideal platform for scale up or scaled
down approaches
um bioreactors have different components
which make it all the more flexible uh
to use depending on the application or
your process requirements
uh so these are just some of the
components that a bioreactor is equipped
with
and of course that will change based on
your process needs
uh so for example agitation is
controlled by motor
uh and the impellers that you choose uh
aeration will be controlled by the gases
flowing through the sputter
again based on the feedback obtained by
different sensors like do and ph
temperature is controlled by either
heating using the heat blankets or
water jackets and cooling fingers based
on the feedback provided by the
temperature sensor
in addition to these the controller
systems are equipped for integration
uh to third-party equipment or sensors
like
turbidity or od sensors uh
among others or even peristaltic pumps
to enable
automated feeds during the run
back to you enos thank you
oopsella so uh we went already through
by using shakers and bioreactors and we
gave you
a comparison of the system and now it's
time
to give you some tips on how to shake
and steer cultures
first of all we have now the last poll
for you
to know a bit about what
are your concerns in your cultivation
if you tap if you have some of these
problems please
ah okay
no problems oh no it's sorry
okay contamination seems to be an issue
shear sensitivity
oxygen limitation yes so
and also some of you have no problems
that is also good
keep fingers crossed that it stays like
that you do everything right
so let us see how to shake and steer
cultures
the challenges in shaken and their
cultures are manifold depending on the
system you use
on the culture of the clone you use
oxygen limitations
is a big one evaporation if we go down
to plates or very small volumes or long
cultivation
times for instance viscosity for
instance if
some of you do fungal cells or cultivate
fungi
oops sheer sensitivity we talk here
about more
mammalian cells where you apply lower
rpms
and contamination sensitivity would also
be more
with mammalian cells so um we divided
here the chapters
so first let's have a look on on the
shakers so
what is influence what are influencing
factors when you use
shakers or what set screws you can
adjust so
um the influence influence on oxygen
supply and the set screws are the vessel
type
the fill volume the fill your volume we
advise
to use not more than 20 percent um
if you talk to bio process people and in
this area they even go down to 10
percent
when it's about mammalian cells it's not
that
sensitive you can go up to bit higher
volumes and also here we have different
specialized flask companies for instance
where you can go up to higher films
volumes
on the shaker side you have the shaking
diameter i will explain it a bit
after this slide and the rpm of course
so these are the four set screws so um
again we talked about in the beginning
you have the
so so what is the orbit of a shaker
maybe you have heard of it another name
is the shaking diameter
so let's simply take here an open-air
shaker with a knot
as well drawing here and you have the
flasks on top of the shaker usually in a
clamp or on a sticky pad
and they are rotating and this
rotational motion is called orbital
motion so circular motion
and by the direction of the by the
centrifugal forces you have the swirl
building up in the shake flask
and by this you have the introduction of
the oxygen
so this diameter here by which the
shaker is moving the platform
around the circle is the shaking
diameter or orbit
you will encounter yet different
suppliers and different kind of
shakers have different orbits so
different diameters
from small to very large and
instruments uh when you have instruments
usually a very small orbit is
paired with a very high max speed it's
like if you know from centrifuges
through
it you cannot have a very high speed and
a very large orbit because
it would just be too much power input
for the device
so let's take a mixer a mixer has a very
small orbit
and this is our thermomixer it is a
three millimeter orbit
but you can set a rotational agitation
of up to 3000 rpm um
this device is perfectly suited for
small diameters for instance
plates tubes
so here you see the the curl and for
instance in a deep well plate
is nicely mixed so it's more we talk
here about
mixing a shaker what you find
usually is a 50 millimeter orbit and
this can be agitated up to 300 rpm
and a 25 millimeter orbit which is a bit
higher up to 400 rpm
and by the way when you stack shakers
always
put the higher orbit on
on the ground the relationship between
rpm
and the shaking diameter both
both have an influence on on the oxygen
introduction
here you have let's say a smaller orbit
the 25 shaking diameter and when
you move to another shaker with a 50
millimeter orbit
this will mean that you have a better
aeration
it a higher otr maximum let's say so
here you see a bigger wave a bigger wave
remember from the beginning you have a
larger surface and more oxygen
entering the liquid so doubling the
orbit size will double
the otr the speed as well
if you have 100 rpm yeah you nearly
shake it
but for sensitive cells it's maybe good
for
e coli you go on a very high rpm
200 300 even 400 or 500 you can set and
a higher
rpm means a better aeration as well
but also it means more mechanical shear
forces
so um yes we often get the question what
orbit should i take for what
so the 25 millimeter is like let's say
the universal orbit
you have conicals or let's say tubes
um two bioreactors flask in the range
from 25 to 2 liter
when you only have for instance very
large flask larger than two liter
um or shear sensitive cells or also
plates
then a 50 millimeter is beneficial for
plates also a three millimeter if you
have a mixer
with a plate adapter works also quite
well
that was the shaker let's have a look at
the shake vessels
a diversity or a big variety of vessel
designs exists and
suppliers make their best to create new
formats
um with them yeah with with
with adding aids to to help to increase
the aeration
so well designs are different and
optimized you have
tubes with a conical button and here for
instance
the baffles we come to it in the next
slide and maybe some of you use also the
sandbag design
and this is uh you remember from the
beginning
the surface area for oxygen transfer in
the fanbot design is very much enlarged
because you have just a wider flask
this is i think very good to understand
so these are
these two the baffles and fanback
designs are designed to improve aeration
let's look a bit deeper before you have
to make the decision and now we come
also to the contamination prevention
topic
to use glass or plastic glass is the
traditionally used
material it is cheap you can re reuse it
and for flasks that cleaning is not
so much of an issue autoclave it
and also it if you have for instance
yeah bacteria
culture which have a problem
with oxygen limitation problems
it supports also glass is hydrophilic
the liquid is hydrophilic and
imagine you have this curl the swirl
swirling around
the flask and hydrophilic likes
hydrophilic
as you remember so it curls up the sides
and this means an enlargement of the
surface and you see here on the right
side maybe the small
and the hydrophobic flask the oxygen
at the hydrophilic flask the red one is
higher so you have a better
oxygen transfer the risk combat
contamination of course is higher
on the market of course when we go to
pharmaceutical or product safety
the trend is to going to plastic there
is of course a minimized risk of
contamination there are
diverse materials here in the center so
a bit milky flask is polypropylene
um for for bacteria polycarbonate or
yeah there are other
plastics because of the leachable
topic or mammalian cells are
quite sensitive there are different
plastic types you hear polycarbonate is
used more for mammalian cells and you
see it it's as clear as the one on the
left side as glass
you have um also yeah the it comes
mostly with
the really at a certain sterility
assurance level
and if the vented filter cap is um
[Music]
yeah with the with the vented caps are
usually have a 0.2 micrometer filter in
it
yes now we come to the baffled and the
non-baffled flask
and the the trick or the the
aeration um improvement is here by
having some kind of defined cavities in
the bottom
as you see here so and for instance if
you shake e coli and normal lb
culture at 150 rpm so not as high
you see that the buffet culture is
has a has a faster growth
so it is definitely beneficial to use
when you only can apply lower speeds or
if you use
higher filter volumes or also with
viscose liquids so
fungal fungi cultures or other viscose
cultures the baffles are
beneficial to use one problem with the
baffles
as you see here i don't know if you see
it probably the right one
you have foam formation and you see it's
a bit more turbulent
but that is no problem because there are
a lot of anti-foam
solutions in the market and you add a
couple of
microliter and that
then the foam vanishes because at lower
speed it's not such a problem but at
high speeds the foam can hinder
the oxygen from passing the air to
liquid
barrier let's say the last topic
about shea about shakers shaking vessels
is a very
small volumes deep well plates they're
the issue are
sedimentation and
if here is the tip reduce fill volumes
if you note
any sedimentation curse so it's always
beneficial to
do growth curves in the beginning with
maybe different fills
and we noted good settings that you just
take either
yeah the fifth depending on the orbit
you have 50 millimeter with 300 rpm
25 400 or if you have a thermal mixer
1000 rpm
and then you will have a good growth and
if you have still sedimentation then
you can reduce the fill here for
instance is 500 micro micro liter
took oh so one milliliter works well
and evaporation is an is another problem
so here just a tip if you use a ceiling
film
and you see it's a gray gray here
you have more evaporation if you have
long cultivation times
there are special clamps for instance
which can reduce evaporation
um available
so i with this i think you can we have a
handling website so if you have your
phone ready uh please check the qr code
and i would hand over to my colleague
ankita
to tell you a bit um about the
bioreactor
configuration thank you ns
so talking about the proper bioreactor
configuration um selection of an ideal
bioreactor and a controller system will
depend on the type of culture or
application as well as the process needs
and requirements
uh which will influence aeration uh
mixing and impeller type
the different types of sensors or
the tools that are going to be used in
the process
so in the next few slides we are going
to dive into more details on
some of these critical features that
should be considered for selecting the
appropriate bar reactor
for any process
so the first factor that we'll talk
about uh which needs to be considered
while selecting a bioreactor is the
material of our vessel
glass versus single use bioreactors a
typical glass vessel consists of a glass
body with a stainless steel head plate
which is used to connect different
sensors
tubings impeller shaft with the
impellers and other components in the
bioreactor
now glass vessels have been
traditionally used in the industry as
they are autoclavable
and leachables are not an issue when
you're using glass vessels
however um single-use vessels provide
high product safety
since the entire vessel has been
pre-assembled so there is no risk of
cross-contamination
you have non-invasive do and ph sleeves
in these vessels which further help
reduce contamination risks as the head
plate integrity is maintained
and not user dependent uh here is a
quick flow chart comparing the workflows
when using glass versus
single-use vessels um substituting the
traditional glass bioreactors with
single-use equipment
can greatly simplify the bar process
workflow
single-use process eliminate the need
for cleaning as well as autoclaving
this reduces the time needed to prepare
the bioprocess run and lowers the
contamination risk
since these vessels are pre-sterilized
all you would have to do is connect the
vessel to the controller
and fill it up with media to prep for uh
calibrations
another big advantage especially at
larger bend scales is the lower weight
of the plastic vessels compared to glass
thereby reducing um occupational hazards
associated with
overweight handling thereby making this
more ergonomic
the next critical component of a
bioreactor is the impeller selection
so you can see here how different types
of impellers cause different flow of the
medium in the vessel
a radial flow occurs when the fluid is
pushed away from the impeller's access
towards the vessel wall
actual flow occurs when fluid is pushed
up or down along the axis or the shaft
of the impeller
so the orientation of an impeller
whether it's a left or a right handed
and its agitating direction will
determine
uh whether the direction of actual flow
is up or down
a typical rusting impeller causes radial
flow
whereas pitch blade impeller causes a
combination of both radial and actual
flow
so we'll talk a little bit more about
these impellers in the next slide
so rusted impellers are usually flat
bladed
impellers their blades are flat and set
vertically along the uh
agitation shaft which produces a
unidirectional radial snow
russian and russian type impellers can
commonly
be used in fermentation of cell lines
that are not considered shear sensitive
including yeast bacteria and some fungi
as they help achieve
high otr and high shear
the blades on pitch blade impellers are
flat and set at a 45 degree angles which
produces a simultaneous axle
and radial flow uh this combination
provides better overall mixing and
creates a high
uh otr compared to the unidirectional
marine blade impellers
so pitch plate impellers are low shear
impellers designed to gently mix the
contents of a culture without causing
uh cell damage and they are most
commonly used with mammalian cell lines
uh or cell lines which are grown in a
suspension or even with the aid of micro
carriers
and then we have the marine impeller uh
which produces the actual flow so like
the pitch blade impeller the marine
impellers are used for applications that
require
gentle mixing however
due to the uni-directional flow the kla
values of marine blade impellers tend to
slightly be
lower than those of the glitch plane
now let's talk uh uh let's talk a little
bit about some of the process controls
that the bio reactors offer
bioreactors are equipped with a do uh as
well as a ph sensor
um which are constantly reading the
cultural conditions
in terms of the percentage of do as well
as the ph of the culture
uh these sensors are constantly sending
an input back to the controller system
and based on the feedback that the
controller receives from these sensors
it initiates a response to ensure
that the doo and ph are maintained as a
desired set point
so for example for a typical ph control
um
by uh the feedback response the
controller is trying to
maintain the ph at a set point by
involving the flow of
acid or carbon dioxide as well as the
base as required
here is an example of a typical deo
cascade for fermentation
uh wherein agitation gas flow rate as
well as oxygen
or pure oxygen are used to control a do
at the desired set point
if you look closely at this graph you
can see that
as the do output percentage increases uh
which means that the do percentage is
drifting below the set point
the controller makes attempts to
eliminate this drift so the first step
uh that will happen is the ramping up of
agitation
followed by adding the gas flow rate
increase
and then finally by introducing the pure
o2 sparging
in a typical cell culture run the
agitation often stays constant because
the cells are usually
shear sensitive and you only use air as
well as
your oc pure oxygen to control you
uh many other process parameters can
also be monitored and controlled by
simply integrating different sensor
types with your bioreactor system
so for example you have biomass readers
like od probes or turbidity sensors
metabolite analyzers for reading glucose
lactate and other products
uh you have exhaust analyzers which are
constantly giving
otr ctr rq readings uh redox sensors
uh as well as options to include uh
sensors from uh
which have uh which allow for multiple
measurements like um
an hplc nmr or uh
cdx uh or agilent technologies uh or
nova biomedical products
uh let's talk a little bit uh more about
uh the feeding strategies of uh in
bioreactors
so the first one that i'm going to talk
about is the cultivation strategy uh
which is the batch fermentation
or this strategy was used in one of our
application notes to describe an e coli
growth
uh in culture uh the slide describes a
batch fermentation mode where cells are
seeded in a bioreactor and the nutrients
are gradually consumed
all the while metabolites continue to
accumulate which is similar
a little bit to the shake flash culture
so over time the culture environment
changes wherein the nutrients are
completely depleted and the byproducts
accumulate
uh which eventually causes the cells to
move into a stationary or death phase
so the maximum od obtained in this run
was about 77
um here you can see a typical growth
curve which is divided into the lag
phase
uh stationary phase and eventually the
uh that phase
uh where the cell density and viability
drops
and of course you have the exponential
phase uh here
uh in the next uh slide i'm going to
talk about a fed bathroom
in this strategy uh once the cells are
seeded into the fermenters uh they are
allowed to grow as a batch culture
until nutrients are consumed as can be
seen by
um this drop of glucose concentration
around day five or six in this craft
here at this point
fresh nutrients are then added in
increments throughout the remainder of
the run to consistently maintain the
nutrient
concentration and culture which you can
see by the jump in the oxygen
concentration starting day seven
however uh metabolites like ammonium
constantly accumulate in a fat batch
culture which could eventually become a
limiting factor in cell growth
uh using this technique the exponential
uh growth phase as well as the
stationary phase can be extended to
achieve a higher ods compared to a
single
simple batch culture so for example in
this study an od of about 240 was
obtained uh
compared to just the od of 77 in a batch
culture which we saw in the previous
slide
the third feeding strategy uh is a
continuous fermentation
mode so as you can see in the picture
here um
in a continuous fermentation process
fresh media is being constantly added to
the fermenter at the same rate at which
used media and cells are simultaneously
being harvested from the reactor
thereby there is a constant supply of
fresh nutrients for the cells and the
toxic metabolites are being constantly
removed from the culture
so either as the rate of addition of
fresh media is the same as the rate of
removal of spent median cells
the culture volume remains constant
throughout the run
and an audio of about 159 was obtained
at about
10.5 hours in culture here
uh please uh feel free to refer to this
app note that we have uh if for more
information on these feeding strategies
and you can also use the qr code to
access it
back to christian
so thank you enos and ankita for this
for this great presentation
as i promised you in the beginning um
and before we before we will start with
the last problem the q and a session i
promised to
give you a little product insight into
helpful solutions for your daily work
and i would like to show you um
a few shakers here and also some
bioreactor
solutions and i would like to start with
the innova
s44i incubated shaker which you can see
here
and with that incubator shaker you can
achieve higher flask capacity which you
can see in the graph here
so um whatever type of vessel you you
will use you will find
a high flask capacity in the innova 44
and you can check out also the um the
comparison for the vessel type you're
you're normally using um you can also
shake faster for higher protocols so
even in a stack
you achieve a high um
shaking shaking speeds to
um to really um be ready for high-yield
protocols with specialized class and
you can see here in that little picture
also that
that the shaco includes reliable shaking
with high loads
24 7 um with this new appendoff x drive
which has five eccentric sets and four
peripheral
that really supports the the load in the
periphery of the platform
and if you want more information you can
go to evandorf.com
s44i
next thing i would like to show is the
co2 incubator shaker new brunswick s41i
which you can see here
which includes um on the bottom part the
shaking part and
also you can include the static shelf
for static incubation
since this is based on appendage u2
incubator technology
it also includes 120 degrees
disinfection here
there's no fan outside so every smooth
chamber that you can use so a high
capacity
and you also don't have to worry about
those
containing boxes here and to how to
clean them so
together with the high temperature
disinfectant it's really easy
um to provide high contamination
prevention here and it also
because you have two doors here one
inner and one outer doors according to
the c2 incubator setup
you have significantly reduced gas
consumption which you can see here on
the
on this little slide here and
also what customers always say it's uh
it has a
comes very quiet operation if you're
interested in more
evandorf.com s41i
now here comes the dustbox mini
bioreactor system
um which features four-fold units for
parallel processing
it supports process development
following the
qdb approach and there's also
integration of third-party analyze
and doe tools you can check out the
whole system under appdoc.com
dustbox it can be extended to
24 parallel operated bioreactors and
comes with a working volume of 60 to 250
milliliters
and currently new is the bioblue
0.3 sc 8 8 blade impeller system which
is special
actually designed for for stem cell
processes
and the last one is the latest
bioreactor system from appendoff called
siberio twin it's the next generation
bioreactor control system which you can
see here
which features 19 different vessel
variants glass
and bioblue single-use vessels and
especially
designed for stem cells cell culture and
fermentation applications
it offers you increased flexibility and
advanced application efficiency and if
you want to know more
about the siberia twin here go to
ebendorf.com
by vario all right so let's come to
our last fall question here so we can
keep improving our webinars for you so
the question is how do you rate the
content of today's webinar
we highly appreciate your feedback to
really improve here
so i hope the survey and the poll gets
pushed out
so we have at least
some minutes left for a q a session
um so if you have any questions you
would like to ask
enes or ankita please do so just click
on the ask question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we will answer as many of your
questions as we have time
left for which is not much but keep in
mind
that we will answer or ankita and enos
will answer all of your questions so
nothing is lost and i
see there are some questions coming in
i think i will start with the first one
i'll check this out and
so we have one question i don't know
who's
going to get this here how many
different sensors can be integrated into
one
bioreactor vessel so i guess that's for
ankita
yes thank you christian um so uh
that is a good question actually uh that
depends on the size of the vaseline the
head plate
so um of course you have typical or
basic uh
parameters like do sensor as well as p8
sensor uh
which will need to be measured during
your run other than that you also have
uh biomass readers that can be
incorporated like an
od sensor for typical fermentation runs
or
capacitance probe which are also used
for biomass readings
uh you can also have a redox sensor
included in the run depending on
your type of application as well as
glucose sensors that can be included
so i think that answer kind of depends
on your type of application or the cell
type that you're running
thank you ankita um here comes another
interesting one
uh the question is is it possible to
measure the kla and the shake class
that probably goes to enos
yes that's me so measuring the kla
so the aeration efficiency in a shake
flask
yes that is possible it is less common
because
it's just due to lack of equipment or
lab facilities
because the two methods applied are yeah
the guessing
out method which needs um nitrogen
gassing and this is not very often
available for
with the shaker and the second missing
sulfite depletion method
yes you can apply and it is beneficial
also to
measure the kla and shakers especially
in bioprocess development if you would
like to compare the klas between the
different system shaker bioreactors
for instance one topic and to verify the
settings and the optimal
culture conditions and yeah as said you
can
there are available for shake flask
oxygen sensors and so on so it is
for sure also possible and recommendable
to measure
the kla and shake shake flasks
all right thank you inis okay i think
we are pretty short on time but i think
we have time for
one more last question so i have to
choose wisely oh this is an interesting
one
so the question is i have problems with
foaming in the fermenter
so do you have any recommendations thank
you
thank you christian um so forming in a
fermenter
is actually a very um uh common uh
observation
uh coupled with uh spurging and
agitation
uh uh creation of uh uh gas bubbles
during spurting
uh can actually lead to forming so
there's absolutely
uh something that you can do to
mitigate this issue so there are various
anti-formations available
uh that you can use uh to mitigate this
uh
forming issue uh if you add just a few
microliters of these anti-foam agents uh
that will help supp uh the foam subside
and
uh will prevent uh any issues from
further forming
uh absolutely
thank you ankita for this uh and also
enos for this uh
short q a session as i said please uh
send your questions if you have any to
both of them
and we will answer um all of the
questions
so thank you again and ankita do you
have any final comments for our audience
ah no thank you it was uh nice
for us as well yeah now thank you for
listening
thank you for attending see you next
time hopefully when it's about steering
and shaking
okay before we go i would like to thank
you all for joining us today and for
your interesting questions
uh questions we did not have time for um
and those you have submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
the speakers by the contact information
you provided
and i would like to thank enes and
ankita for their time today
and their very nice presentation we
would also like to thank michelle ashton
and the lab boots team for supporting us
today
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab roots will alert you via the email
when it's available for replay and we
encourage you all to share this email
with your colleagues who may have missed
this
live event today so we say goodbye from
hamburg and from
san francisco bay today have a nice day
and most importantly
stay happy healthy and help to protect
others
thank you and goodbye goodbye see you
next time
goodbye